well i think
a lot of people try to translate word
for word and i you know that's why i'm
telling them about syntax so they can
start to think in lines because
translating word for it's very it's very
labor-intensive kind of thing and it
makes you make more mistakes the
language is is each language is
different but there are common basics in
each language and so there's a there's a
syntax there's grammar there's
vocabulary and there's reading writing
listening and speaking so it's how you
approach those things that makes those
those core skills that make the
difference and so your awareness of how
to get to those skills and how to you
know what you need to know makes you
move faster
um i think there's kind of a transition
period that a lot of people like to go
through they like to kind of compare
languages they find that oh that's what
they say in the song that's how they say
it in my language but you know what i'd
like people to to move them through that
transition period like yeah they're you
know enjoy that kind of you know
comparing if you if you want to do that
but then get to the part where you
actually can think in the language and i
want to show you how to do that because
that's really key is you want to think
in that language because translating
back and forth that's it's exhausting
and it's unnecessary once you know how
to to the language works and how you can
use a couple of comments that the uh our
approach is to say no jargon and no
explanations
unless the learner asks for an
explanation
so we don't teach a bunch of
explanations but if the learner says
like why or what does this mean
we don't really like the question why
does this happen this way because that's
an unnecessary just it happens okay what
does it mean i got all the words i still
don't understand it that's a legitimate
question here's what it means
uh with regard to issues such as you
know speak to
you know i listen to him i hear him why
i don't i don't even want to know the
explanation i just say to the person you
save the word listen in our system and
you look at all the phrases you get and
they'll all be listened to
and then you say the word here and it
won't be here too
so after a while you'll get used to it
because the explanations are not that
helpful and i'll give you a very good
example from chinese
in spoken chinese there's no difference
between he and she
there is no chinese person who speaks
english that doesn't understand the
difference between she
and that doesn't know that in english in
spoken english there's a difference and
yet
many chinese people will get it wrong 50
of the time because it's not something
that they're programmed to do based on
all of their years of doing chinese and
i've had the experience many many times
when you correct someone or you explain
an error they say thank you very much
and they just get it wrong the next time
and the next time the next one
absolutely so what you have to do is you
have to get people to notice to see
to hear you get them to notice the
language and you prod and whatever you
tools you use we happen to encourage
people to write we think writing is a
very good way because it's a record of
what you're saying and we correct things
in the writing and then the words and
phrases that you used incorrectly are
put back into your flashcards together
with the words and phrases that you're
collecting from your listening and
reading
so those are some other ways but the
whole
insofar as connecting to your native
language the big thing to me is the
dictionary i think the bilingual
dictionary is the key tool everything
else should be in the native language in
the target language as much as possible
but you need to get that little sky hook
that little hint it doesn't tell you the
whole story
about the word but it kind of gets you
there quickly and because mostly you're
motivated or should be motivated to
understand the context that you're
listening to in reading and that's why i
agree entirely with robin that phrase
books are useless you know the idea that
you're going to go to country x and go
to the bank and say i would like to open
an account the way they have it in the
phrase book and they'll come back at you
with such a torrent of whatever
that you won't know which one does and
then you switch back to english say well
really what i meant to say what can i
open an account so phrase books don't
work because the phrases are all
disconnected context is important
interesting context something you're
interested in you're listening you're
you're gleaning words and phrases from
of it from it so that your whole
language level is growing
and the idea that you can shortcut the
system by learning some key phrases
it ain't going to work
where's the toilet that's kind of useful
but beyond that what you want to know is
how to reuse this structure in different
ways because those structures there and
you can use them in exponential amount
of ways and that's what makes you a
powerful speaker in the language so you
can see how to reuse those things and
that's really important i totally agree
about the dictionary the great thing
about the dictionary if you look at it
it's a language in your hand so for
people who are very visual learners you
can see the language in your hand you
can hold it in your hand and so in any
language even in english i don't know
every word the dictionary but i'm always
happy to learn a new one and that's kind
of the sense you have to feel when
you're learning another language to
choose that you're not going to learn
every word you're not going to know
everything that's in the dictionary but
you can use it as a tool to track your
progress what i recommend people to do
is if you learn